ja ich glaube es ist besser es ist schon
richtig das Russland
in einer machtpolitisch gesehen
bedenklichen Situation ist wir müssen
auf deutsch gesagt langfristig den
Abstieg Russlands als Weltmarkt managen
denn demografisch gehen sie im Keller
sie sind von ihrem Gas und Öl nur
abhängig auf Dauer halten Sie diesen
Status nicht durch das hat ja Präsident
Obama schon richtig erkannt ob das
politisch klug war damals das ist
dahingestellt sein das ist ja vollkommen
klar und dass dieser Akt in der Ukraine
völkerrechtswürdig war auch ist auch
klar wegen dass wir den Ukraine eben
helfen ist auch in Ordnung aber wir
müssen das politisch klüger machen ich
wir dürfen nicht einseitig auf
Waffenlieferungen setzen wir dürfen
nicht äh davon ausgehen dass wir eine
militärische Lösung hier herbei Bomben
werden und das das dann alle nach Hause
gehen und dann ist Frieden nicht sondern
wir müssen versuchen aus dieser
militärischen eskalationslogik
irgendwann rauszukommen weil das Risiko
eines Dritten Weltkrieges eines
nuklear-krieges massiv hoch ist in
Afghanistan konnten wir nach Hause gehen
nach 20 Jahren
tausende von Soldaten verloren es hat
es hat Millionen 100 Millionen Dollar
gekostet nicht da konnten wir einfach
gehen das geht hier nicht und Russland
kann da auch nicht raus aus der Box der
steht da mit dem Rücken vor der Wand
wenn er dort raus geht ist Russland am
Ende ist nicht nur Putin am Ende das
geht nicht Stichwort
Sicherheitsbedürfnisse stärker beachten
strategische Interessen in der Region
auch sehen ja das sind unsere
strategischen Interessen wann sind die
Russlands der Ukraine der Amerikaner ja
es ist natürlich ein Freiheitskampf
eines Volkes was man unterstützen muss
aber es ist auch ein Stellvertreter
Krieg zwischen den USA und Russland der
da läuft da geht's um geostrategische
Interessen handfester Art genauso wie
die Chinesen das im Südchinesischen Meer
haben oder die Türken die auch parallel
Krieg führen im Nordirak und Syrien
gegen die Kurden über die niemand redet
gleich weiter
um seine Einschätzung bitten Sie sehen
ja ganz viele Sachen anders als Herr
Vater aber haben wir denn als
Deutschland überhaupt die Chance aktiv
einzugreifen
ja wir haben die Chance wenn nämlich den
ukanern beizustehen in ihrem Kampf für
die Existenz und das Überleben ihres
Staates und ihres Volkes
diese Möglichkeit haben wir und deswegen
ist die Lieferung von Waffen richtig und
wir sollten so viel liefern wie möglich
dass man weiter diplomatische Kanäle
versucht zu errichten und zu bespielen
das ist ja vollständig klar das ist
geradezu banal dass man das alles tut
aber dazu gehört auch dass man die den
Bankrott in gewisser Weise der
Diplomatie gegenüber dem was die
russische Politik in den letzten zehn
Jahren war dass man das mal analysiert
dass man analysiert warum die Putin die
eskalationsdominanz behalten hat und bis
auf den heutigen Tag und die
eskalationsdominanz besteht darin dass
er ein Teil der Ukraine jetzt zum
Staatsgebiet Russlands erklärt und jede
Verteidigung der Ukraine jede
Verteidigung durch keinem zu einem
Angriff auf Russland erklärt und damit
und die mit den Atomwaffen droht das und
da möchte ich wissen von Leuten die
immer nach der diplomatischen
Lösung das ist für mich ich möchte
wissen wer bringt jemanden an den Tisch
an den du an den Verhandlungstisch den
den Tisch umgeworfen hat und der
überhaupt nicht die
Logik müssten sie halt weiter kämpfen
dann viel Spaß ne ich sehe nur die
militärische Lösung da eben nicht und
das ist eben der Punkt
hat das übrigens mal gesagt da war ein
ziemlich knallharter israelischer
general ich selber kurz vor seinem toten
noch kennengelernt und der hat
er hat die Araber wirklich von Herzen
gehasst und abgelehnt und er hat Kriege
gegen arabische Länder geführt die
Israel damals angegriffen haben aber er
war der erste Außenminister Israels der
gesagt hat wir müssen Frieden machen mit
ihnen und er hat kann sehr stark unter
Druck in der innerparteilich auch und er
hat dann mal gesagt ja wenn du Frieden
willst reicht es nicht mit deinen
Freunden zu reden du musst mit deinem
Feind reden bei jeder Geiselnahme ja
macht man das große Staatsmänner ich
denke mal die Schlüssel sage ich mal
liegen natürlich nicht gerade in Berlin
und in Brüssel das schon richtig ne also
das ist schon eher eine Sache der USA
und da wünschte ich mir dann auch von
Deutschland ein bisschen mehr Druck in
diese Richtung ich meine ja unser
Kanzler sollte auch mal nach Washington
fliegen und auch mal mit den Amerikanern
reden weil wir müssen ja gemeinsame
Lösung finden mit unserem wichtigsten
Bündnispartner da raus aber
da profitieren auch gerade ja Amerikaner
liefern Waffen verkaufen Waffen große
Stil die Amerikaner haben sind ein Netto
energieexporteur für die sind hohe
Energiepreise super also bei der ist es
eigentlich super die haben genau
einen kleinen Rivalen fertig machen die
einzige Frage die ich über die nicht
verstehen verstanden habe ist warum die
Amerikaner ist als Ziel haben könnten
das Russland und China aneinander rücken
weil das ist auch so dieser Nebeneffekt
wo ich auch sage wir machen alles
natürlich für die Ukraine es ist ja auch
in Ordnung es geht ja nur um die Frage
wie viel und wie wie klug ist es und wie
weit gehen wirst was wir aber auch
machen ist wir treiben die Russen
regelrecht in die Arme der Chinesen
nicht das verschlechtert unsere
geopolitisch geostrategische Lage auch
hier würde ich gerne noch einmal ähm
Schlögl eine eine Frage habe ich und
zwar
viele Fragen sicher ich weiß Mutmaßungen
das möchten wir auch gar nicht mehr
viele fragen sich ja wie weit entfernt
das Kriegsende ist oder wie nah ist da
möglich eine Prognose zu sehen ob der
Krieg noch ein halbes Jahr geht ob der
Krieg noch zehn Jahre geht ob da wie da
das Zeitfenster ist also wir sind keine
Propheten wie der Kassandra noch Profit
wir wissen es nicht wir wissen nicht
einmal was morgen und übermorgen
passiert und das müsste Herr wart am
besten wissen er hat ja den Überfall
kommentiert also stimmt ja er hat ja
kommentiert und was mir auffällt an
diese Diskussion es ist wieder überhaupt
nicht die Rede davon was in Russland vor
sich geht es passiert etwas worauf ihr
auch nicht gefasst waren das
hunderttausende 300.000 junge Menschen
sind in den letzten zehn Tagen an die
Grenzen gefahren und sind rausgefahren
wegen der mobil machen es hat in
Dagestan in Jakutien ist Demonstrationen
gegeben es hat in vielen Städten
Manifestation gegeben es passiert etwas
worauf wir die wir alle schon uns daran
gewöhnt haben zu glauben das Putin der
Mann der die Stabilität garantiert nein
er ist nicht der Mann der die Stabilität
garantiert sondern der die Zerstörung
Russlands als eines Staates bet